Okay.
In the last lesson I brought up the concept of the verb as a function word that
has a number of different arguments.
We didn't really go into the implications of that statement,
but we'll start to unravel it this time.
Like other verbs give has a number of slots that take a certain number of nouns
are pronouns give has three of those slots.
To be specific.
It expects three arguments,
so I give it to him.
Make sense?
But I gave it kind of withholds information were expecting and I gave,
leaves us with two slots that are not filled as I described before.
Those slots are filled by arguments,
which are nouns and pronouns.
Let's talk about the number of those arguments.
Verbs can be described by their [inaudible],
which is a fancy way of talking about the number of arguments that a verb
requires.
Valence is specific to a single verb,
a verb like run,
expects one argument,
the subject,
so it's called monovalent.
Divalent verbs expect to like the verb.
See,
okay,
I see it.
She saw them try.
Vaillant verbs include give as an,
I gave it to him.
The label monovalent divalent and try Vaillant depend on the core arguments,
the arguments that are required for normal use of the verb in question.
We can of course add extras in the form of adjuncts.
She saw it on Thursday,
she saw it on Thursday with her brother,
et cetera.
We can look at it another way by focusing on transit tivity transitivity
considers what type of objects to verb takes.
Transitive verbs take a direct object.
I say John sees her because see takes a direct object in this case her in
transitive verbs to not take a direct object.
You would say I slept,
but probably not.
I slept them because sleep is an intransitive verb.
We can make a further distinction between intransitive verbs and die transitive
verbs.
I gave it to him as both a direct object and an indirect object,
so it's a dye,
transitive verb.
Defective verbs are curious class and they include verbs with only one fairly
meaningless,
phenomenal subject.
That subject fills a grammatical function.
The so called whether verbs are great examples,
it rains,
it snows,
it hails.
Those all have a subject it that we don't switch out for another subject.
Like Steve Snows the Pronoun.
It is a dummy pronoun that just stands in the slot simply because we expect to
have a subject.
This isn't a full fledged argument here,
so when it comes to valence,
see,
we call these a Vaillant verbs.
That's a good way to start thinking about the number of arguments that a verb
has come around.
Next time we're going to start discussing the type of arguments.